hey there guys so i've got something a
little bit different for you today i'm
here at curlington quarry waiting to
meet liam ellis who is a fantastic
parkour athlete and like martial arts i
think parkour something can benefit
everyone so i think parkour moves have
something to offer people even if they
don't necessarily have an interest in
parkour and free running if they don't
have an interest in becoming a parker
athlete you can benefit from learning
these moves just like i think everyone
should you know hit a heavy bag from
time to time we'll do some shadow boxing
because it's so good for you
so today i'm going to hopefully learn
some moves from liam and at the same
time we're going to see how he adapts to
this different environment so here he is
here's liam what's up
it's me guys
yeah what do we uh
what do we want to talk about we're
going to look at how parkour can be
useful for you know anybody not
necessarily a free runner or an aspiring
free runner and at the same time see
what we can find here because it's a
little bit different than your typical
parkour environment that's also partly
you know the thing because if you're not
into parkour and free wedding you're
probably not going to want to like go
into a town and leap off the wall
because some people feel self-conscious
about that yeah man well we're gonna
we're gonna try and adapt to the forest
which actually i've been loving doing
recently because it's uh it's a whole
different style of movement and parkour
you can kind of look at it and sometimes
think uh you know there's certain
categories of movement which there are
but it's to me it's a lot more of a
naturalistic way of life where you
you're
you're putting your body into into
different scenarios testing your fear
elements but also letting it
um
letting it move in its natural capacity
depending on whatever environment it's
in because i mean we really are built to
do parkour plus as a bonus you get to
see me fall on my ass again probably
lots of times and then you know not make
a video for a couple of months
that's the aim of the game today that's
the flange of your favorite youtuber
yeah
yeah awesome cool man all right let's
get it let's get warmed up and get
started huh
fun little fitness game you can play all
along the beam try and push each other
off grip strength core strength for
proprioception you know right now yeah
get all the way down trying to keep the
back straight
toes facing forwards if you can heels on
the floor and you basically you want to
be able to get to this position because
whenever you're doing a landing it's
always like the more flexible you are
here
the less likely you're going to have
undue pressure to a knee or an ankle or
something like that yeah so when you
watch any uh knees over toes go oh dude
i took the program i did yeah yeah yeah
because
and it made such a difference to me like
oh because of course you had your knee
yeah yeah oh what a testimonial yeah i
kind of so i go heel down and then i
roll over and then come back that's cool
let's teach you how to roll all right
you want to do that yeah yeah yeah well
i feel as safe as possible have very
limited experience with this used a
little bit of karate then try to do it
on my own i didn't know about diamond
shapes that should give you a clue as to
how not clued in i am
see so hands like this yeah which
shoulder do you think you want to roll
over
slightly to the right yeah and then
you're gonna you kind of make a an arch
with this arm yeah as you go over and
then you hit that back shoulder and i'll
let you go first yeah so then you just
like
hey you're perfect man yeah was that
right it was like spot on oh was it yeah
right i didn't land in this in a
in a squat as you nicely did you're
gonna land and then roll yeah yeah so
yeah it's going to be like
in yeah fine
yeah looks nice
landed jump bang
yeah nice that didn't feel too bad yeah
that was sweet dude that's fine you got
like the important part is that you've
got the background time i hit my head
so okay yeah so always avoid your head
yeah because if that's concrete that
would be a no yeah you're jumping over
your knee
and that's causing you to bump the back
right so you you want to get that knee
like out of the way and then you're
you're here okay
yes look at that that felt better
beautiful
so first first one you want to learn is
just
up and over just like a normal
this is a normal classic vault first
thing you'll learn
so it's two hands your feet are going to
go to one side whatever's most most
comfortable and then you put foot put
foot down to just sort of guide yourself
over it depends because like i
presume that you're probably just
confident yeah this this is pretty yeah
yeah right exactly if you're if you're
first starting this the natural
progression is
like this
and then over so you just use that foot
yeah perfect and then it's like sort of
jumping into that foot and guiding over
yeah exactly and then it's then it's
just a case of up touch down
yep and then all the way over
this you funnily enough as much as you
would learn this first you'd never use
it yeah because it's just a it's a
clunky vault yeah so um to make it look
pretty yeah we would do like a thief
fault so a thief bolt is you start with
one hand and then you put your back hand
on
afterwards
yeah nice didn't that second your hand
right yeah
yeah yeah that makes any sense yeah so
it guides see that you're up
and it guides you
across
nice so now just try the same thing but
take off your inside leg because at the
moment you're coming like this and just
swinging that leg over if you come from
the inside leg then you can get a nice
flat and kick over
so the inside leg is going over first no
you take off your inside leg oh i see
was i jumping off this one yes ah
yeah so that's harder
yeah nice cool so now you know you can
get over as long as you can trust that
back hand you'll you'll sit down into it
so you'll be like you can lean back and
push yourself away okay and that'll give
you some momentum exactly yeah yeah yeah
something that's already apparent is
that i'm much more comfortable going
right rather than left yeah if you are
just starting this it's well worth
doing both sides and not developing
handicaps right yeah i'm just gonna say
can i just do this no
good nice yeah and then just grow to
trust that backhand so you're in and
you're like
i'm pushing off this one
it's so much more natural nice going off
of the uh the other foot yeah but it's
not if you're running if you're like
running forwards
so like if you're if you're running
forwards ah yeah yeah of course that
might be
yeah there are look and it worked and
what i like about this move is that is
the um you're coordinating your upper
body and your body right right and
that's one of the big things that buckle
and gymnastics and everything that's so
great for is the throat reception and
yes and moving in that way and you know
yeah instead of moving everything
independently individually you're moving
it's a learning experience for the whole
body yeah you start to get a real sense
for
exactly where every body part is and how
it kind of works together
um especially when like because now
right like my
my form of practice for parkour isn't
like how do i get this technique better
it's how can i more trust myself to do
what i already know how to do yeah and
turn my mind off in that regard
yeah do you want to learn another bulb
yeah definitely sweet
so um if you're if you're trying to get
like some real speed yeah when you're
running you want to do what's called a
speed vault speed bolt take off your
inside leg and land on the same leg and
your aim of the game is to actually keep
your body upright and then you'll you'll
take off and your legs will do this and
you'll get out of the way so it's a lot
of rocks here
so you're like here
like this okay cool so i'm basically
hurdling it and just tapping it with my
own and tapping it yeah okay it's mostly
a hurdle but then you balance yourself
with the one hand gotcha
sorry
yes mate nice cool most people don't
land on their same leg the first time
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
because the whole idea of the speed
vault is that you have the momentum to
keep running so if you're here and you
come down that's the closest leg and
then you run away most people just go
like a common a common attempt at a
speed vault at the first will be they'll
use their hand too much they'll take off
and then go
like that yeah sure the idea is to run
jump turn tap and keep running
[Music]
nice that's it yeah you can get a little
bit more of a sideways turn because you
you you've really hurdled there so do
think of it like you are turning a
little bit
yeah see you're in
well that's cool
okay
yo nice man
that's sick so other other foot oh
yeah cause you're good hi nice
yes sir all right so you think of
parkour as like a set like gymnastics
you've got like set moves that you have
to do to perform with parkour like
anyone who really practices it it's more
about finding
like just fun little challenges like
this like nothing about this has a name
like there's no name to this um there's
no parkour specific move it's just like
oh we found some fun
tree in the forest and now we're going
to try and do this thing with it and
it's like in just enjoyment parkour to
me means like enjoying myself through
any kind of movement yeah that's what i
mean like that's that's what we wouldn't
go for something else we could learn on
this is a palm sphere might ah pounce
into austin oh you could do them yeah no
no i can't oh okay i like them i like
watching them one hand here to get you
around and then one hand like this to
support you yeah grip the tree yep keep
that arm pretty straight yeah and you're
basically just going to swivel round on
this arm so you just jump up into a
tuck in sort of a very vertical motion
yeah
yeah so how do you feel when you first
feel it bad right okay
very bad
okay so a good start is hand on the
floor and then ah yeah over like this
right
yeah cool yeah i can't wait
no cartwheel
that's it yeah yeah i'm worried i'm
gonna try your hand like just up against
the tree a little bit now
that's it yeah try taking off of two
feet because that's how you're going to
want to do it
yeah great man that felt better yeah
that was great two more of those
nice that's so cool
with the kong vault you might be a
little bit like
worried about catching your feet yes
that's exactly what i'm worried about
the first thing you want to do
is just practice like doing a kind of
hands-on tuck jump so you're here
and you're just trying to get
your feet almost to like
touch
yeah you're going to be fine yeah if you
can do that
from going over it still not really so i
mean it is but like the next move is to
go like this and just take your hands
off hands
just off as you come up
cool you got a nice balance though on
the
thing as well
so up and balance and it's yeah look at
that exactly and then then you can just
start going and just dropping over right
yeah yeah
nice well that immediately feels a lot
better than i thought it was going yeah
and you've done it yeah there you go
nice one man killed it so it's just up
back you do like a real sort of
yeah yeah yeah well when you're here
well the thing is eventually this is
like learn to do kong free pre is short
for precision which means right if you
land on something landed
somewhere you know nice
nice mate yeah
you've learned this super rapidly the
next thing you have to learn is the
gallop step like so to take off properly
right i just want you guys to be aware
that this is a really quick learn like
it learns very very quickly if you're
just stuck on this step for a long time
like that's pretty normal but i would
say this is a fantastic piece of
training just just let that you talk and
if you wanted to make it a training
exercise as well you could just do up
and then like stand up so you're like
hit and you have to like balance oh
stand up yeah go
it's not gonna work
yeah nice feet a little a little further
apart when you land
about there and then like a good a good
test of um how good your squat is is can
you do it on a row
yeah
yeah so like
yeah you're up
nice that's it you keep that chest back
and just trust in the balance yeah nice
all right so now this is the what bolt
is this so this is this is still a kong
but we're learning how to take off and
like run
the idea is basically you jump into a
split foot now people tend to go feet
together you want to jump in like one
two yeah hands come on and then you just
do the kong as you would before right so
you can take it slow okay so the only
difference really is the it's the steps
yeah but you are you're also leaning
forward a bit more and it's less of like
a because with this you've got all of
this down momentum to bring you up yeah
but when you're running into it it's
more of like a i'm already over the bar
yeah so it's almost like is it similar
to the vault in the fact that you're
already traveling over it and you're
just using your hands to sort of help
yeah right yeah yeah basically
it's a there's a lot more hand
involvement but less so than from static
so yeah just demo for one for you so
you're here come
in okay cool
yeah okay okay so you're you're kind of
really trying to avoid the bar with your
feet at the moment
you're coming in and going like
like yeah
you know what i mean yeah that's how it
feels yeah and i'm landing like yeah
whatever that is so it's it's more like
down and then chest up
because when i when i do it as more of a
dive it feels better but it also feels
more like i'm gonna yeah
well that's why it's like down and then
chest up
[Music]
low and then
up and look
i was exaggerating but
yeah but can you see that you've got
you've also got that one leg that's just
doing this so you do both legs both legs
come through the middle yes
if you think about it like you're
galloping so you you take off and then
it's like one two makes it a lot easier
uh one two yes all right yeah
i
yeah yeah yeah absolutely
it's so such a shame that we're just
we're just so limited
in what we're allowed to do why is it so
weird to like to play
yeah you jump on i think yeah but it's
already a computer game but if you play
by climbing on something yeah
yeah you're super weird
try not to fall victim to that status
quo also you don't have to be doing like
crazy moves like if you don't do that
you can just do something much simpler
and easier you don't have to be at risk
at all you just have to like experiment
be creative have fun with it
allegedly they come from monkeys you
know what i mean like for me it's it's
way way less about um learning
lots of skill sets it's about
remembering the kind of movement that
you should be able to do naturally yeah
just to say massive thanks to liam
thanks man thanks for stopping by yeah
that's been brilliant learned so much i
hope you guys have as well yeah it's
also been a blast like loads of fun if
you if you're interested in any uh in
parkour stuff we take you around like on
my vlog parkour journey as we take you
around from town to town like exploring
different places watching how new people
move and trying that out ourselves if
you're up for that parkour journeys yeah
and you've got some great videos on like
mobility and stuff as well don't you
right yeah yeah yeah so but like as a
parker athlete like it's like some of
the most impact you can take so i've had
to really take care of my body and learn
how to do that so i've got some some
good stuff on there that you might be
able to
use enjoy yeah yeah no it's brilliant
stuff and the videography is beautiful
so highly recommend it link in
description down below you also find
there my ebook and trading program super
functional training as always if you're
interested in training that's not just
lifting weights or looking good or
running further then you'll probably
enjoy that too um either way thank you
so much for watching this one guys leave
a like if you enjoyed it comment down
below let me know you've dabbled in
parkour and i'll see you next time
thanks a ton
whoa
bloody show off and bye for now